there's no reason at all why we can't
bankrupt Bud Light overnight if if every
person who identifies as conservative or
at least isn't on board with this stuff
just said I'm not going to buy that
anymore because like you could sacrifice
it and it would mean nothing to your
life whatsoever and if everyone did that
or even if 40 percent of people did that
they would take such a hit that they
would have to come crawling on their
knees begging for forgiveness there's no
reason why we can't do that we just
don't some of this is we got to take
some lessons from the left on some of
the things we talked about this before
but some of the methods that they use
and the tone that they use we can direct
it in in the right direction One Thing
the left is very good at is they pick
targets and a gang up on them and they
make an example of them unless very good
at making examples of people and we need
to do that I think a lot of
conservatives don't have the they don't
have the stomach for that but we need to
find victims and make examples of them
maybe Bud light's not the one because
they're a big Target but some other
company that goes the weather that goes
the woke direction we say you know what
we're making this company our project
we're gonna we're gonna take you down
and destroy you to make an example